I like old school graceful skiers just
seems so like Kim we're old bab we're
old I think it's all about the
snowboarding news days I think known
each other when do you know yeah I
remember the exact moment I met you it
was it was maybe six years ago you were
in B and I Remember You Walked In you
were like hi and that like nice voice
you have you don't talk to me like that
anymore she doesn't give me the nice
voice anymore now it's like hey what's
up yeah she's like what's what's up no
it was like slightly higher pitch just
very friendly yeah it was the yeah it
was the OG kid yeah you still do it yeah
do you not remember meeting
me babe you have to I don't remember
like a 6' four like handsome British man
in your house the amount of people that
would write me at the beginning being
like who is him set me
up like I don't know if he's in the
girls guys like I don't know oh